Joe Biden is appointing more judges to
the federal bench and you knew they
would be bad but did you ever think they
would be this bad
judge
on the far end
uh tell me what article 5 of The
Constitution does
Article 5 is not coming to mind at the
moment okay how about article two
neither is article two
okay
do you know what purposivism is
in my 12 years as an Assistant Attorney
General and my nine years serving as a
judge I was not faced with that precise
question
Senator Kennedy
was not grilling these judicial nominees
on some Arcane obscure aspects of
federal law
he was asking them about some of the
most basic provisions of the fundamental
American legal document this wasn't what
does U.S code section 27 line 52 it was
what's Article 5 of the constitution do
they didn't know
and conservatives are now shocked and
appalled but we should not be
these Libs don't need to know these
judge nominees don't need to know Biden
and his minions did not nominate these
judges because they're experts on the
Constitution he didn't nominate them
because they love the Constitution they
they keep a pocket constitution on them
every day and they want to do everything
they can to uphold it it's the opposite
Biden nominated these judges to continue
the liberal project of upending our
entire political order if anything their
blight ignorance of the Constitution is
likely a mark in their favor
when you look at it from the perspective
of the people who are putting them up
for these jobs I'm Michael knowlesus the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Master kiyahi
who is reacting to that attack on Dave
Chappelle where those transgender
protesters were throwing eggs at him
Master kiyahi says privilege is being
able to throw eggs in this economy so
true privilege is being able even to eat
eggs forget about wasting these even to
just buy a dozen eggs that's a real
privilege have you have you heard what
the prices are for eggs lately have you
talked to your friends around the
country when you do want to talk to your
friends around the country you got to
check out pure talk right now head on
over to puretalk.com use promo code
Knowles if one of your goals this year
is to do business with companies who
share your values then check out Pure
Talk Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it is proudly veteran
owned employs a us-based customer
service team and absolutely refuses to
spend money on fake news networks not to
mention Pure Talk service is fantastic
they are one of the largest networks in
the country you can get blazing fast
data talk and text for as low as 30
bucks a month that's probably half of
what you're paying Verizon ATT or
T-Mobile switch over to Pure Talk in as
little as 10 minutes while keeping your
phone and your phone number your first
month is guaranteed risk-free try it if
you're not completely happy with the
service you will get your money back the
service is as good as whatever cell
phone company you're using right now I
can tell you that it is
much less expensive it's run by people
who don't hate your guts who actually
like you customer service in America is
super easy these guys are great making a
goal this year to support companies that
support you go to puretalk.com enter
promo code knows save 50 on your first
month puretalk.com promo code Knowles
Pure Talk is simply smarter Wireless
speaking of unimpressive Biden
Representatives
Hunter Biden
you know has dipped his toe into the art
World Hunter Biden's previous career was
selling his father's influence in the
American government to make oodles and
oodles of money in Ukraine and China and
from all sorts of Nefarious and corrupt
people who wanted to buy more influence
in the American government Hunter I
think referred to this in one of those
disclosures that came out from the
laptop or some other conversation as uh
hit that the fact that he makes
basically a bajillion dollars a year so
that's how he previously made his money
but then when it all came to light it
was much harder for Hunter Biden to
continue the Biden family corruption so
he said okay the way I'm going to start
making money now is by painting Hunter
Biden I don't think had ever picked up a
paintbrush in his life until about five
minutes ago and his painting is just a
bunch of ridiculous Doodles on a canvas
that we were then told could sell for
half a million dollars each
this another example obviously of
corruption nobody thinks that Hunter
Biden's stupid Doodles are high art
nobody thinks they're worth fifty
dollars much less five hundred thousand
dollars
but the art dealer selling Hunter
Biden's work is insisting no this is not
just corruption this is not just a way
for people to to pass half a million
dollars into the Biden family without
having to go through political
disclosures this is not just another way
to buy influence with the bidens No No
Hunter Biden's a great artist Hunter's
dealer George Berge the owner of the
eponymous Art Gallery in New York
praised Hunter Biden's artwork said
Hunter Biden will become one of the most
consequential artists in this Century
because the world needs his art now
more than ever
in a world that beats us down we need
art in our lives that reminds of the
unrelenting Divinity within each of us
and if you'll excuse me I will get right
back to the show I just need
sorry
I'm sorry okay now that I've emptied out
my my gut and stomach here
from that absolutely nauseating and
disingenuous Praise of Hunter Biden now
we can go on with the show
why is he saying this well he wants to
have a straight face he wants to say no
this isn't corrupt at all this isn't
ridiculous Hunters Hunters Doodles
deserve half a million bucks pay up
let's go nothing wrong about this
but I think the other reason that the
art dealer and Hunter and the whole
Biden family can get away with this
is we don't have any power to stop it
I read a statement like that
I see judicial nominees put up who don't
know the very first thing about the
Constitution
and I think man they're just rubbing our
faces in it now aren't they they're just
lording their power over us they're
saying oh yeah
yeah we're gonna pack the court full of
people who have never looked at the law
ever
a bunch of just completely ignorant
people who will do what we want them to
do and you can't do anything about it
oh
oh you don't like that we've had some
Corrupt Practices okay well now the way
we're going to make money is by selling
my my derelict Sons scribbles on a
canvas
what are you no no he's a great artist
that guy he's basically Michelangelo
what are you gonna do about it
conservatives nothing that's what
they're gonna do
speaking of Art
and speaking of one way conservatives
have pushed back in the culture we
played yesterday James O'Keefe's
excellent expose of an executive at
Pfizer confiding in someone he that he
thought he was on a romantic date with
that don't tell the public but Pfizer is
secretly performing gain of function
research to beef up viruses to work on
on new Pharmaceuticals
and the date says what what Pfizer is
working on gain of function research and
the exec says yeah I mean we don't tell
the public that but we are working on
that and then
just yesterday James O'Keefe releases
the footage of when he walks out like
Chris Hansen comes and sits down he says
hey hey I think I'm gonna have a seat
over here what are do you work for
Pfizer did you we've got you on camera
admitting to and
things go awry
hey there is your seat taken you work
for Pfizer my question for you is why is
Pfizer want to hide from the public the
fact that they're mutating the covet
viruses is this real life I'm literally
a liar I was trying to impress a person
on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way don't tell anybody he was just
working in a company
you really did please
can you please unlock your door no no
don't let them leave please unlock the
door
please unlock it please unlock the door
please unlock the door
unlock the door
that is the the director of worldwide r
d uh specifically on mRNA strategic
planning that those are the people
who are behind the the fouchy ouchy that
that has now gone into the arms of five
and a half billion people worldwide this
lunatic who's out on on what he thinks
is this date and then he he just loses
it starts getting violent running around
oh my gosh is this real life oh my gosh
and then what's his excuse
this is my favorite part
the minute James I keep says hey we just
got you on camera admitting that
Pfizer's doing a function research he
goes I'm a liar
that's his excuse I'm a liar I was lying
and that's always what these guys do
this was just a modern day version of To
Catch a Predator the Chris Hansen the
show that would get pedophiles this is
just that hey why don't you what are you
doing here
don't you have a seat over there what
are you doing here
and instantly what happens all the time
the guys on the To Catch a Predator show
who want to sleep with underage girls
they say oh I wasn't doing anything no I
didn't I didn't come here to have sex I
didn't know not at all I was just I was
just lying in the chat oh no all those
logs you have of me talking to this girl
about how I was going to come over and
drive 12 hours and sleep with I was just
lying it's the same excuse from the
Pfizer exec no I was just lying well the
problem with that excuse is if you are a
liar if your best defense is that you
are a liar then obviously I can't
believe you now
and it's not just this Pfizer exec this
was fauci's excuse do you remember fauci
initially said when kovid broke out
and the Liberals at that time were
downplaying it before they started
overplaying it fauci said there's no
reason to wear a mask
there is no reason when the virus is
spreading around for you to wear a mask
out in public do not wear a mask and
then five seconds later he says you have
to wear a mask everywhere all the time
wear like three of them
what changed fauci admitted how he
changed his mind
or or changed his rhetoric because he
didn't change his mind he said oh yeah
when I told you you didn't need to wear
a mask I thought there'd be a shortage
and I wanted to save them for my friends
but then I found out there was an issue
so I told you to wear them so Chi's
excuse was the same excuse as the Pfizer
exec was the same excuse as the pedos On
To Catch a Predator
I'm a liar I'm a liar don't believe
anything we say okay
all right guys if that's what you want
I'll I'll take your word for it I have
no doubt that you guys are big Liars
speaking of
virality and and social media big news I
meant to get to it yesterday we didn't
have time
president kofefe
El Donaldo himself
is back on Facebook
meta which is the parent company now for
Facebook and Instagram and all the rest
of it
they've announced
quote we are bringing Mr Trump back in
the coming weeks with certain guard
rails applicable to any public figures
suspended for certain violations during
times of civil unrest
the penalties and potential restrictions
that we've put in place are a deterrent
and Trump could face another suspension
if he keeps breaking the rules
why are they letting Trump back
it's been years at this point
it's been two years
why does he get to come back now Elon
put him back on Twitter
even though Trump isn't using his
Twitter yet probably because he has
contractual obligations with truth
social
but Elon put him back on
so maybe that puts a little pressure on
Facebook Trump is now a declared
candidate for the presidency I think
that probably puts a little pressure on
Facebook but but
probably the biggest Factor here
is that the January 6th The Narrative
fell apart
the reason that Trump was banned from
social media the reason that these
oligarchs in Silicon Valley who work
with but not totally through the
government they're this awful Blobby
public-private kind of partnership that
does the bidding of the government the
government's Dirty Work they can't do
for itself but also is completely
unaccountable to the people
the whole argument for Banning Trump was
that this guy led a violent insurrection
a near coup d'etat on January 6th and
that didn't happen
we know
because we've had two years of
Investigations into this
they told us Trump
incited the Insurrection well we have
the video Trump says be peaceful be
peaceful don't be violent go home
okay there goes that one well
nevertheless the the followers of Donald
Trump they were they were so violent
they killed people they killed police
officers that's not true the only person
who was killed in political violence on
January 6th was Ashley Babbitt she was a
trump supporter in the capital shot by a
trigger happy cop
well what about officer Brian sicknick
officer Brian sicknick died of natural
causes
after the January 6th Riot he did not
die in any violence on January 6 nor did
any other cop
well
they nevertheless even if they didn't
kill anybody even if they weren't
particularly violent even if Donald
Trump never incited anything they they
were still leading an Insurrection okay
then how come none of them were charged
with insurrection
how come they were charged with
trespassing
I mean the prosecutors threw the book at
these people they threw them in solitary
confinement
for long periods of time
but they couldn't they couldn't get a
charge of insurrection because it didn't
happen
so the whole thing just it just fell
apart
a whole thing fell
apart so now they let Trump back on I
think there is one ulterior motive here
beyond that the the libs couldn't quite
withstand the pressure of of still with
a straight face saying that Trump
couldn't be on Facebook I think the
other ulterior motive is the libs want a
bloody GOP Primary and the thinking
back when they were trying to keep uh
Trump off the ballot in certain places
back when they were trying to throw
Trump in prison I guess they're still
trying to do that back when they were
keeping him totally ostracized from
social media the the prevailing view was
that Donald Trump if he ran for
president 2024 would clear the
Republican field so there would be no
Challengers he would be the nominee
automatically
and so the libs were throwing everything
they had at him that no longer appears
to be the case Ron DeSantis among others
seems to be building a pretty strong
campaign for president
it's still Trump's race to lose Trump is
still way up in the polls but
DeSantis is posing a real challenge to
Trump right now other people are saying
they'll run too Mike Pence is saying
he's very interested in running Nikki
Haley says she's very interested in
running Tim Scott says he's very
interested in running so it just no
matter what you think of those people or
Trump trump did not clear the field and
so now the lib strategy has to switch
and they're going to want a more bloody
GOP Primary which means they're probably
going to be much more interested in
allowing Donald Trump to be on platforms
such as Facebook in fact you saw a
similar principle
just a couple of days ago
with with the azov Battalion in Ukraine
for years the azov Battalion which is
filled with neo-nazis in Ukraine was
banned from Facebook why because it's
filled with neo-nazis
but now Facebook is on the side of
Ukraine fighting against Russia
and so the enemy of my enemy is my
friend and the azov Battalion is one of
the most powerful regiments in the
Ukrainian military
and so Facebook says okay never mind
they're not Nazis anymore or even if
they are they're they're like the good
Nazis okay we're going to let them back
on Facebook
why so that they can attack Russia
almost certainly there's a similar
principle operating here with social
media companies allowing Trump back on
but we're not
we're not quite there yet we're not
we're not at a 2024 nominee yet we're
not even totally into the primary yet
first what has to be decided is who's
going to lead the Republican Party
meaning the party apparatus meaning the
RNC the National Committee there's a
fight right now between Rana McDaniel
who is has run it for about a dozen
years now
and Harmony Dylan Harmony Dylan has been
on the show I don't think Rana I think
we invited Ron on but Rana hasn't hasn't
come on yet uh harmey Dylan is
challenging Rana saying enough's enough
Ron has been there long enough uh now
I'm going to take over the RNC
Trump has endorsed McDaniel
now finally
Ron DeSantis has weighed in as another
rising star in the GOP
he endorses hermit Dylan
right now the RNC is meeting in Dana
Point California and there are some
questions of who should lead the RNC and
whether it should be Rana for a fourth
term or go a different direction with
Harmony Dylan what are your thoughts on
this well we've had three sub-standard
election Cycles in a row 18 20 and 22
and I would say of all three of those 22
was probably the worst given the in the
political environment of a very
unpopular president in Biden a huge
majorities of the people think the
country's going in the wrong direction
that is an environment that's
tailor-made to make big gains in the
house and the Senate and State House
State houses all across the country and
yet that didn't happen and in fact we
even lost ground in the U.S Senate and
so you know I think we need a change I
think we need to get some new blood in
the RNC I like what harmeet Dylan has
said about getting the RNC out of DC why
would you want to have your headquarters
in the most Democrat city in America
it's more Democrat than San Francisco is
notice Ron DeSantis he's a very Adept
politician he's he's asked about the RNC
where do you stand on the race and he
gives something of an answer he says
well rana's not getting it done we need
fresh blood
and I like harmeet Dylan's idea about
getting the committee out of D.C
so it's not it's not quite it's not a
full explicit endorsement of our meet
Dylan
but practically speaking it is
and why is it I suspect well one it
might be just that Rhonda Santos
sincerely believes that all of the
things that he's saying but in politics
there's always another layer too and I
think the other layer here is Rana
McDaniel is a trump person Ronald
McDaniel is very closely tied to Trump
ran the RNC during Trump's presidency
Trump has endorsed Rhonda McDaniel and
so
what does Ron DeSantis get if he
endorses Ronald McDaniel
nothing
the big dog in the fight has already
endorsed her so so that puts DeSantis in
a position of being number two
what does Ron DeSantis get if he
endorses Harmony Dylan and Hermie Dylan
wins now not only does Ron DeSantis have
a friend running the National Committee
but Ron DeSantis has also racked up a w
against Trump which has been the
narrative that's taken place since the
midterms The Narrative since the
midterms is Trump he just couldn't pull
us over the Finish Line Trump he had an
unimpressive performance I'm not saying
this is a fair assessment I'm just
telling you this is the narrative that
has taken hold
and then when you compare that to the
incredible success in Florida undeniable
success DeSantis and the Republicans of
Florida did a great job turning out the
vote and getting themselves elected and
re-elected
that is being considered a W for
DeSantis and an L for Trump and so if
Hermit Dylan can beat Rana McDaniel in
the RNC leadership race
that's going to look like another
victory for DeSantis over president
Trump is this going to matter for the
nomination
maybe not but but the race to the
nomination is every single day
and if you win enough days you win the
nomination that fight picking up right
now but we're not fighting each other
we are not ultimately fighting each
other some people prefer Trump Some
people prefer DeSantis Some people
prefer Ted Cruz Some people prefer Nikki
Haley some we're not but ultimately
we're fighting the libs ultimately we
conservatives have a lot more that unite
that unites us than
we have that divides us especially when
you look at how crazy the libs have
gotten and I sometimes forget it because
increasingly I spend my time around
conservatives I come from a liberal
place I've lived in Liberal cities I've
got liberal friends going back many many
years but I do spend a lot of time with
conservatives I sometimes forget how
crazy things get and then I read the
Associated Press trying to ban the word
the
before I get to that this week I told
you and we all got one step closer to
the crunch in our breakfast cereal
coming from Bugs not whole grains the EU
officially enacted a statute allowing
food producers to incorporate Cricket
powder into its flower-based products
not because it tastes better but because
the political Elites have deemed that
eating Z bugs is better for the
environment so right down to the food
you eat the world wants to make you woke
but not
Dennis Prager Dennis wants to make you
wise and the founder of prageru is going
to do just that with a never-before-seen
series exclusively on daily wire plus
called the Masters program with Dennis
Prager what the master's program aims to
do is take 40 Years of wisdom and
experience from one of the most
influential conservative thinkers in
America today and distill it all down to
its Essence he covers topics such as the
consequences of secularism such as is
human nature basically good it is as
thought provoking as it is Illuminating
the first two episodes of prairieu
master's program are available to stream
right now exclusively on daily wire plus
so head on over to dailywireplus.com
become a member and watch prageru
Masters program and more that is
dailywireplus.com today
the word the is canceled
according to the Associated Press
the AP which through its style book that
sets the tone for a lot of Journalism
and public writing has become more and
more woke in recent years the AP says
quote we recommend avoiding General and
often dehumanizing the labels such as
the poor
the mentally ill the French
the disabled the college educated
instead use wordings such as people with
mental illnesses
and use these descriptions only when
clearly relevant
as a style point this is bad writing
style
because a general rule in writing is it
is better to use fewer words than more
words cut out unnecessary words close up
space and generally speaking your prose
will improve political correctness tells
you to use lots of extra needless words
to to use euphemisms instead of clear
language and confuse everybody
but clear writing says be succinct be
concise be precise
the AP also doesn't follow its own
advice Ezra Levant over at the rebel
pointed out that the AP has regularly
referred to the unvaccinated probably
because it wants to dehumanize the the
unvaccinated but you're not allowed to
use those labels for anybody else and
everyone's covering this as an example
of political correctness run amok which
in part it is but there is something
deeper going on here behind the move to
take away these group categories the
poor the disabled the college educated
and and it's it's something that infects
it's a it's a mind virus that has
infected the left particularly but it
has infected the right as well which is
that this is a consequence of liberalism
this is an attack on group identity per
se
this is a logical extreme of the liberal
idea that we are all fundamentally
individuals not members of a group
I know that a lot of conservatives and
self-described conservatives
particularly of the last 50 years
have grounded their political views in
individualism but that is not a
conservative idea that is a liberal idea
you could say well it's more of a
classical liberal idea some people would
say it's actually much more of a modern
liberal idea the classical Enlightenment
liberals who talk about the sovereignty
of the individual or the modern
Progressive liberals who talk about how
how we have ownership of our body and if
we want to chop off our body parts
that's all right because we're
individuals we're we can't be defined by
our social mores or our laws or our
customs or even our families no by golly
we're we can't be defined even by our
biological sex no siree we're
individuals well all that obsession with
individualism that is a lib thing the
conservatives
believe with the Ancients with Aristotle
with Christianity with the greatest
thinkers of all time that man is not
fundamentally individual but man is a
social animal man is a political animal
that we find our identity in society
with other people
that we find our our identity
in our families in our communities in
our duties and our obligations and our
role in the world
the French
the college educated
the disabled
suggests that people can be
categorized in groups
obviously that's true obviously there
are distinctions between groups of all
types of groups
the Liberals don't want to admit that
they don't want to admit that they are
that there are such things as group
characteristics group behaviors group
dynamics but obviously there are and you
see it reflected I mean this is the
entire point of my book speechless
controlling where it's controlling Minds
which is available now number one
National bestseller where is it guys get
on the stick okay fine good grief we got
producers sleeping over here today this
is the whole point of my book speechless
is that
the way that the libs win the culture
most effectively and most consistently
is not by passing big laws and not by
having big flamboyant campaigns it's by
subtly changing our language to make us
accept their incorrect premises before
we even begin a debate
so if we say okay we're not going to use
the anymore to refer to people we are
accepting the premise that people are
fundamentally individuals that groups
have no uh shared characteristics that
that groups are not a a real and
politically Illuminating category but of
course that is not the case speaking of
Journalism
great story right now out of BuzzFeed
that has has really
proven old nylstradamus more and more
correct every day this week which is
that we we started off
talking about how
AI passed a business school test
Business School exam
that was the big headline an AI chat bot
passed a Wharton Business School exam
Wharton is probably the best business
school in the country and I said you
know it's not just going to be business
school you're going to see this for
lawyers you're going to see this for
doctors what happened the very next day
headline the AI chat bot
passes or gets very close to passing bar
exams and medical licensing exams
okay and I said the takeaway from this
is that the elites are going to tell you
that Automation and artificial
intelligence technology that's going to
get rid of lots of jobs it's going to
render whole segments of the population
useless the way that someone like Yuval
Harare and and others associated with
World economic Forum describe this as
they'll say oh these useless people
these blue-collar workers these
unskilled workers we're just going to
apply them with drugs and video games
make them go away because because
technology is going to make them
irrelevant and I said that's not true in
some limited cases that's that might be
true but the real people that technology
will render jobless
it's actually white collar workers it's
actually managers who would go to
Business Schools actually accountants
it's actually some lawyers some doctors
for for certain basic programs and now
we're finding out that the people who
need to go learn to code or go get
another job it's going to be journalists
because BuzzFeed
is just announced that
it will start using artificial
intelligence
to create content not just to curate its
page and algorithms but actually to
create the articles that you like look
at on BuzzFeed our industry will expand
Beyond AI empowered curation feeds to
ai-powered Creation content AI opens up
a new era of creativity where creative
humans like us play a key role providing
the ideas cultural currency inspired
prompts IP and formats that come to life
using the newest Technologies
the the coming
Industrial Revolution we sometimes hear
this from the world economic Forum types
Cloud Schwab he'll say via in the force
Industrial Revolution
and this is supposed to make all of us
you know unskilled useless people uh the
the regular the hoi polloi who don't
France around the alpsa Davos this is
going to make us all irrelevant
if there is a coming
Industrial Revolution that throws people
out it's going to affect the white
collar people and they're going to have
to learn to code or
learn something else
we have now arrived at my absolute
favorite time of the week that is the
mailbag sponsored by puretalk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter code
Knowles Canada wlas you get 50 off your
first month take it away
Nostradamus my knowledgeable Lord of All
Things conservative Italian and or cigar
related I have a question about role
models does the type of person people
look up to matter even if they speak on
subjects like traditional masculinity
one example I thought of was Andrew Tate
and Jordan B Peterson both speak up for
men relationships and mentality however
Tate is surrounded by a number of women
materialism is more aggressive while
Peterson is a family man psychologist
and is very careful in his delivery so
as the type of person that people look
up to matter even if they preach
positive messages I'd love to hear your
stance on this now I'm going to put
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds in my shopping cart I hope I get a
bell
are we gonna get a bell hello hello
everybody there we go okay good I'm glad
to hear that great question
yes Role Models matter
Role Models matter because human culture
comes from imitation this is one of
those rare points on which the Ancients
and the moderns the philosophers and the
scientists the
wise people and the atheists all agree
see what I did there Plato
Renee Girard Richard Dawkins all agree
human culture comes from imitation a
process called mimesis
the little baby learns to smile because
the little baby is feeding and looks up
at mommy and mommy looks down at the
baby and mommy smiles and then the
little baby mimics that smile this is
how we learn to speak this is how we
learn to think this is how we are
educated and learn to behave
this is how we develop personalities
is we see people see things that we
admire and we try to imitate parts of
that and
ultimately if we want to have a good
holy virtuous life we want to imitate
the highest good goodness himself
Christianity sees this not even in only
an abstract God far away from time and
space but in the Incarnation and so
Christians strive to imitate Christ
human beings are not just disembodied
heads floating around in The Ether
human beings are
souls and bodies hylomorphic beings
moving around in time and space real
beings and so we
it's not enough to just listen to a
little snippet and say oh that Andrew
Tate fellow he had something that was
almost broadly true about this one
narrow topic no when we have Role Models
those are models to imitate and we
imitate people not just in certain ideas
that they espouse but in the way that
they live their lives next question
good morning Michael Knowles my name is
Nicholas I just wanted to see if this
terminology correlated with your
perception as well it seems like the
center left uh and the center right uh
are distinguishable by the central left
having much more of a grounded
foundation in their ideology and
certainly the way that their vote the
their voting habits because even if
they're presented with a strong argument
on the right they're much more likely
much more often to remain stable in
their Central leftist
uh perspectives a central rightist
perspective if they're given
in their interpretation a strong
argument from the left a way that they
immediately wouldn't be able to
ideologically combat at the time they're
much more easily swayed to then
politically vote on the left rather than
remaining stable in their right ideology
I just want to see if you concurred
thank you so very much have a good
morning
really good question I'll try to break
it down this way we think of Politics as
left versus right
but you raise the the issue of these
people in the center
left and the center right and then we
just tend to put those people in the
categories of either left or either
right that's why I refer to them as
Center left or center right but
the people who are Center left or center
right I suspect have much more in common
with one another
certainly than they would with people on
the right the conservatives and perhaps
even a little bit more in common than
they would with people
on the left though the center left and
the center right are closer to the left
then either is to the right
you can think of the people on the right
as the conservatives
you can think of the people in the
center Center left and center right as
the Liberals
and I think you can think of the people
on the left as some shade of Kami
marxists or some some more radical
leftist ideology
uh
the
commies and the Liberals share a lot
because communism Marxism all those
shades of socialism come out of
liberalism
so they've got a fair bit in common
the conservatives the real conservatives
reject not only communism but liberalism
not just in certain policies but they
actually reject the premises of
liberalism they reject some of the
high-flying nonsense that comes out of
the Enlightenment they say no actually
Society is not fundamentally secular
there's no such thing as a neutral round
man is not fundamentally an individual
tradition is an important thing we
shouldn't rely on our unfettered reason
we shouldn't recreate the world Anew we
don't want to constantly have
revolutions so that that's kind of a
different that's a different thing
the center left is always going to be
more influenced by the left than the
center right is by the right
and the center right is always going to
be more influenced by this by even the
center left than they are by the right
the outliers I suspect in all of this
are
the conservatives we talk about how the
conservatives are the silent majority of
Americans I don't know that that's the
case I do think that a lot of people do
have common sense that something really
working for the conservatives and I do
think that the actual commies and pinkos
are a relatively Fringe margin the
antifa weirdos who chop off their body
parts and diether hair all crazy colors
that is fringe there's more
conservatives than that group but
because that group has a lot in common
even with the Liberals and because the
center right is actually part of the
Liberals
overall they can wield a ton of
influence on society
that is why they squish
because the squishes share the
fundamental principles of the left not
of the right we call them center right
because they agree with us on some
issues but they're
at the foundational level
we're pretty far apart next question
hey Michael I've got a question about
family planning so my husband and I have
three small children and we're really
not ready now or possibly ever to have a
force
um just financially speaking the
Dynamics of our family Etc so we're
looking into our options and I I've kind
of come to the conclusion that the birth
control pill is not quite biblical I
mean it seems like once the sperm and
egg come together life is already
starting to happen and now you're
preventing it from implanting so I went
off of that months and months and months
ago but I mean I feel like I'm rolling
the dice every month here so love to
look into vasectomies but I was
wondering what your thoughts are on that
you know our vasectomies fair game since
technically you're not even letting a
sperm meet an egg in that instance you
know
um yeah just love your thoughts Michael
thanks well certain forms of
contraception do not merely uh prevent
the implantation of a sperm and a
negative come together to create a new
person but just prevent ovulation
that's probably the dominant form of
contraception anyway in the dominant
forms of contraception whether you're
talking about from the man or from the
ladies uh it's it's
the contraception prevents this sperm in
the egg from meeting
so your bioethical concern here that the
the primary problem with contraception
as opposed to forms of abortion and
aborted fashion drugs is that you're
preventing a a fertilized egg from
implanting that's not quite it it often
starts earlier it's still wrong but it's
it's not wrong because you're ending a
human life
it's wrong because you're supposed to be
open to life
three kids that's great I can't I can't
wait till I get three kids God willing
but come on keep going why Why Stop
three my the only real envy that I I
feel
is is I was talking to another friend of
mine who feels the same way is for
people who have just a billion kids
because it's great it seems great yeah
you don't sleep yeah it's definitely
harder on the wife but then you know you
look someday and you got all these kids
and all these grandkids and it seems
really really nice so be open to life
you say it's expensive it is expensive
I'm not downplaying that
but
in terms of investments in terms of any
way you can use your money a kid seems
like a pretty good investment
seems more important than probably
anything else you're spending your money
on
Beyond food to keep you alive and
shelter to keep you warm
those are pretty necessary the rest of
it is not better than another kid
and then in terms of the vasectomies
there's a reason that men don't go
bragging about their vasectomies there's
a reason that men don't have vasectomy
parties unless there's some weird Libs
in Brooklyn or something is because
men feel that it's kind of emasculating
men feel that it's kind of if not
shameful than something they don't want
to write home about
and I think for good reason
you know it's not quite the same as just
castrating a guy but it kind of looks
the same
it makes a man feel that he's lost
something of his potency and so I
wouldn't do it wouldn't do I think it's
wrong just don't just don't do I know a
lot of people have done it a lot of
people have probably most people today
practice some form of contraception but
oh come on you got a limited time on
this Earth be fruitful and multiply have
kids are great
have more kids next question
hi Michael it's Elise again I have a
question for you regarding yoga I have
noticed that a lot of the parishes in my
diocese are now offering a rosary yoga
class and it's kind of popping up
everywhere my Parish isn't doing it but
I wondered if you had any suggestions
about if I should say anything I feel
like as a Catholic this is really
disturbing Trend I'm not sure if other
areas are noticing this but I'm not
really sure what I can do as
someone who is not a member of those
parishes or if I should do anything but
maybe just speak to the people that have
brought this up to me so I'd love to
hear your thoughts and thank you so much
are those churches that you're talking
about or those parishes also hosting
Catholic Hodges to Mecca
are they also are those parishes hosting
the Catholic Jihad are they hosting the
carrot the the Catholic rather sacrifice
of goat demons to the uh Greek and Roman
gods are they also doing that why
these things don't go together
yoga is a Hindu ritual it's a Hindu
religious ritual
it is not Christian
does not monotheistic it is not at all
compatible with Christianity I know a
lot of Christians go to yoga classes and
they say well I just I like it because
it stretches my body out and it makes me
feel good and okay that's what you can
do Pilates you can go stretching you can
go to a gym not suggesting that but yoga
is not purely a physical exercise
yoga is a spiritual ritual it's a
religious ritual
that's why you do the ohms and you
salute the Sun and you do all and and
depending on how hippy-dippy your yoga
teacher gets you you you engage in
explicit religious rituals
so if if you're going to engage in
religious rituals and you really love
yoga and it's your favorite thing then
then just admit that you're not
interested in practicing Christianity
you are interested in practicing another
religion probably Hinduism or Buddhism
and then you're going to go do at least
be honest with yourself
but but don't pretend that this sort of
syncretic religious practice is
Catholic because it's not they're just
not it would be just as crazy as saying
I'm going to go on a Catholic Jihad
I guess we had some of those called the
Crusades but it's different than Jihad
okay it's just different you wouldn't
say I'm I'm a Catholic Muslim
I'm a I'm a I'm a Catholic Buddhist
you're not you can't you that violates
the law of non-contradiction those
religions make mutually exclusive claims
and you've got to pick one you certainly
don't want to be lukewarm
if you are a Christian you might you
might have read what our Lord tells us
about about being lukewarm in the
scripture it's not great
all right let's take one on paper before
we get to member block
from Christine
dear Michael Knowles do you have any
suggestions on where a young woman can
meet a nice Christian conservative man
I tend not to frequent bars very often
it's probably good instead I prefer to
attend church the gun range and the
grocery store be still my Beating Heart
I'm off the market but you sound great
I'm 30 years old I feel like an old maid
you're not an old maid I unfortunately
work from home I frequent the office as
much as possible but unfortunately not
many of my colleagues like to work in
person it's frustrating thank you for
all that you do that's not a huge
problem and these days in the old days
if you weren't married by 30 that was a
huge issue socially these days if you
get married before 35 you're like a
child bride that's just the culture has
changed in very strange ways but I I
sympathize with your problem it's hard
to meet people especially these days as
we're increasingly living in virtual
reality in the metaverse and we don't
actually meet people in public so I
would be a little more
intentional about it I'm not totally
opposed to the dating apps I've never
been on them I kind of missed that era
but I'm not I'm not totally opposed to
it uh in principle I know people who
have met their spouses on on dating apps
and that's kind of the way people date
these days so I I'd consider that at
least and then you could do it the
old-fashioned way which is to have your
friends and family set you up maybe ask
your co-workers to set you up and it can
be a little embarrassing to say hey
Sheila
you know any good guys you know anyone
that I could hey cousin Jim do you have
any buddies that you think I should go
on a date with you know you I wouldn't
just wait around forever for a man you
know to come in riding on a white horse
Knight and Shining Armor and sweep you
off your feet
if ever that were the norm it certainly
isn't today so you'll have to be a
little bit more intentional but I
wouldn't lose hope you're you're
certainly by the standards of our
culture you're doing just fine you still
have plenty of time you just have to get
a little more intentional about it okay
the rest of the show continues now we've
got a lot it's fake headline Friday I
need your help in in uh sussing out
which are the four real headlines which
is the fake headline and also
buddy of mine is coming on the show very
briefly to talk about his new movie
that's coming out because Greg Perot is
the star of the new Left Behind movie
and Greg Perot
he's got a lot of great credits so I'll
wait until the member block but head on
over the movie uh premieres this weekend
it's going to be a huge Smash If you're
not a member already go to dailywire.com
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
all right